ready to head into both the grishaverse
and wizarding world
we knew there had to be a reason ben
barnes compared his series shadow and
bone to harry potter
well we did a little research and
spoiler alert
he was right prepare to fall out of your
chair when you hear some of the
similarities we found between the
stories of the sun summoner
and the boy who lived as magic
right away you see that both main
characters alina and harry are orphans
sure harry didn't live in an actual
orphanage like alina did
but they both lost their parents at a
young age ironically
their parents also died for similar
reasons while fighting the darkness
alina's were lost to the fold and
harry's to voldemort and his death
eaters
of course because they were orphans both
never realized the power they held
within
is it just us or do they have the same
premise so far
the one chooses the wizard mr potter
we all know how harry likes to use his
chosen one status
but deep down we know that his prophecy
isn't the life he would have chosen for
himself
being the only one able to defeat
voldemort and save the wizarding world
is probably something he could have
lived without
the same goes for alina who was deemed
as the sun summoner
saint and you guessed it chosen one the
whole first half of season one
is her denying that she is the only one
who can take down the fold
she would trade the little palaces
riches and glories just to be running
around in the army with mao
they both unintentionally become
celebrities and quite frankly the most
important wizard
and grisha in their respective worlds
the stag chose me
there is huge symbolism surrounding the
stag in shadow and bone
the stag is one of the miroseva beasts
that would help amplify
elena's already powerful magic however
throughout the series it also acted as a
beacon of light in her life
and something she had been envisioning
since she was a child
harry certainly didn't get a stag's
bones magically placed underneath the
skin of his collarbone
but it was the shape of his patronus in
both films the stag was a form of
powerful light magic that assisted in
getting rid of the darkness
also known as the fold and dementors
overall the stags in both films just
create such
similar imagery if we didn't know any
better we'd guess they were shots from
the same fictional world
just take a look
[Music]
ah fantasy series and their love for
having manifestations of darkness
it never gets old but in harry potter
and shadow and bone
the darkness looks a little too similar
for us to believe it was purely
coincidental
the fold was created by the darkling
alexander after he channeled dark and
forbidden magic
just like how voldemort used forbidden
magic to create the horcruxes in order
to make himself
immortal but these horcruxes were often
life-threatening to everyone else
just like the vulca creatures created by
the fold let's take a closer look at the
fold and what's inside a horcrux
they're basically identical you should
have stayed and
cut it down at the end of season one
elena thinks they've overtaken the
darkling but she couldn't be more wrong
we get to see that he's actually alive
and stronger than ever and ready to lead
an entire army to battle
sound familiar yup it's just like when
the wizarding world thought one-year-old
harry had defeated voldemort
but he was actually very much alive with
an army of
death eaters ready to support him when
he made his comeback
whether or not alina wins like harry did
has still yet to be seen
we just hope people believe he's back
unlike how minister for magic cornelius
fudge
acted about voldemort that's quite
clever
[Music]
has there ever been a myth or tale in a
fantasy franchise that didn't turn out
to be real
alina being the sun summoner was a myth
and yet here we are
but we want to talk about the myth of
the marozova beasts again these were
animals said to hold
such powerful magic that they'd be able
to elevate egretia's power
like never seen before we couldn't help
but compare that to the story of the
peverell brothers in harry potter
also known as the deathly hallows you
have the invisibility cloak elder wand
and the resurrection stone possessing
all three made a wizard basically
immortal and just like shadow and bone
the most powerful wizard not to mention
they play a key role in defeating
voldemort
and is the way to defeat the fold once
and for all
so does this mean there's still hope
we'll one day receive a hogwarts letter
hogwarts is home and also the safest
place to be in the wizarding world
we know that because it's said many
times throughout the harry potter series
that help will always be given at
hogwarts
to those who ask for it
because of its enchantment spells and
dumbledore being headmaster
it's basically impenetrable well the
grisha and shadow and bone have a
hogwarts of their own
the little palace it's the only place
where grisha can truly be safe and
protected from those who still aren't
fond of the small science they use
or from people who haven't forgotten
them for creating the fold in the first
place
ironically they both happen to be grand
castles
to be fair there is one difference
between the two harry actually wants to
be at hogwarts while
elena can't wait to escape the little
palace
speaking of hogwarts all the wizards who
attend are split into four houses based
on their personalities and ambitions
you have gryffindor slytherin ravenclaw
and hufflepuff
grisha on the other hand are sorted into
orders depending on their powers
corporal alky ethereal key and material
in both series these groups are
differentiated by the color of clothing
they wear
and different crests in harry potter the
main colors are burgundy
green blue and yellow for shadow and
bone the colors are blue
red and purple then the color of their
embroidery tells you what their specific
abilities are
basically the only difference is wizards
wear cloaks and grisha wear keftas
the real question is who do you think is
more powerful
not familiar with the concept what would
a good story be
without the strong bonds of friendship
alina and mal grew up together in the
orphanage and quite literally
don't want to live without one another
sure towards the end of the season
things may have been getting
a little more romantic but it was first
based on a friendship where they would
risk their
lives for one another just like the
golden trio in harry potter
harry hermione and ron would do anything
to protect one another
just think about how hermione and ron
were willing to risk their lives and
become fugitives to help harry find the
horcruxes
none of them would have survived the
series without the other
raise your hand if you think platonic
friendships like this are
totally underrated in tv and movies
you know what i mean no
finally let's talk magic or how
similarly magic works in both
series you might be thinking what do you
mean wizards clearly have more
versatility in their magic over grisha
well that's kind of true but they're
both limited in the same ways
grisha cannot create something that
doesn't already exist they can only
manipulate the matter around them
the same goes for wizards sure they can
accio anything they'd like but they
aren't able to conjure things like money
food and clothing those items must
already exist
and if they did summon them it would be
considered stealing
that's why the weasleys haven't conjured
up a vote full of galleons yet
anyone up for a marathon of these two
stories well the idea for a shadow and
bone film was scrapped in 2012
we can definitely see why they had
originally tied a harry potter producer
to the story
but despite the similarities shadow and
bone and harry potter are still
uniquely their own and let's face it
they are probably some of the best
fantasy content
out there did you find any other
similarities between the two stories